and these ceos probably don't have as
much innovation in their behemoth
organizations as a young entrepreneur
sitting in the basement typing out code
and solving problems to make d5 faster
smarter i think we're going to see a lot
of change a lot of disruption a lot of
turmoil and a lot of incredible
investment opportunities into d5 in the
next two years
coming into wonderfuy in this this just
incredible project how did you become
involved with wonderfuy and how did you
and josh richards meet
i just found him so interesting because
he was a a person interested in becoming
an entrepreneur and becoming an investor
and so we really hit it off from that
perspective obviously we do a lot of
work together in social media and
television but when i sat down with him
i said look what do you want to do he
said i'm really interested in what
you're doing in defy i'm really
interested because that's the future and
he's right it's
when you start investing in things like
you know decentralized finance that's
where the puck is going that's the
classic gretzky story you want to invest
where the puck is going not where it is
right now and where the puck is going in
financial services globally is defy and
so the biggest challenge and why i got
into wonderfuy it was originally called
something else d5 ventures i met the
team there ben and his whole team
amazing entrepreneurs i was really
interested in becoming an early investor
and a partner when i find great teams i
go all in and so i started talking to
their team saying look what can we do
together because what he was talking
about and the whole team's mission is is
to democratize defy in other words if
you are an institution and you want to
put you know 100 million dollars to work
in usdc you're going to go to an ftx
you're going to go to a circle and set
up an institutional account but that
doesn't work for 100 million americans
who want to have d5 maybe make some
interest off their bitcoin or their
cryptocurrencies get some income off it
you can't do that easily and so what
wonderfy is all about now is making it
really easy to go into this space and
start investing in it and for me the
reason i got into d5 in the first place
is right now i make basically nothing on
my cash
as you know we're at the lowest interest
rates in history but now when i go into
d5 i can actually make three four five
six percent all through defy and i want
wonderful to make that really easy for
me and a hundred million other americans
and that's really what josh sonnet we
piled in together
and you know from a networking
perspective you know i'm 31 years old i
fell in the media completely on accident
when i was 26 in my first year of legal
practice
because i took and just stripped apart
pokemon go as
mobile ar gaming and those legal
implications for consumers and i found
myself in this whole new world being
able to network with individuals like
you and mark and robert and just fell in
love with bridging the gap between law
and media can you talk about how
today's younger generations whether it's
millennials or gen z
are often missing out on valuable
opportunities to connect with with
people like you and and josh um you know
how has networking played this
instrumental role that you and josh have
come to with with
fi
when you want to become an entrepreneur
don't think about it as a destination
it's a journey it's it's something that
you're going to do for the rest of your
life if you catch that bug it's not for
everybody but it's not about the grade
of money it's about the pursuit of
personal freedom and all of these
investment opportunities and the work i
do with teams like ben's at wonder fi or
josh richards or any of the other
entrepreneurs 30 40 of them that i've
been invested in is talk about my own
journey and try and help them take the
higher road in other words try and avoid
making the mistakes i made that's what
every single entrepreneur does for the
next generation say look here's how i
did it that time here's what worked
here's what didn't and it's kind of like
a mentoring coaching aspect but at the
same time we're investors together we
put real money up and so you know josh's
team as a michael growing and some of
the other guys there are really into
this and i i met them you know years ago
on the set of shark tank and michael's
been around a long time and he's well
known in the community and so we you
know each other and and for me it's sort
of i think this investment fits with
what you're doing josh and i can really
be a part of of you know looking at this
with you and we can do some great stuff
together and obviously when you're
talking about a consumer good in other
words wonderful is going to be an app
it's something you can either get onto
with your laptop or download onto your
onto your
smartphone and that means customer
acquisition costs matters so i've got
millions of followers on social media
josh has millions of followers we're
gonna get the message out the whole idea
is to help the company get people to try
the app and that's the reason you would
want to take you know two teams that are
really supporting social media and my
team and his team and say let's do it
together let's blow this app up because
it's good for everybody involved all of
these are you know sort of in our
thinking and how we can work together
that's exactly what we're going to do do
you do you feel that this is
um
the relationship is any different or
something new in terms of that cross
blend
well you know it's it's always something
new it's always something different it's
always to you know talking to each other
about what everybody's doing i mean the
entrepreneurial space you know gets you
up at five in the morning and you're not
in bed till one at night there's so much
stuff going on right now this is a
golden renaissance in our economy we're
going to achieve probably 9 10 11 gdp
growth in q4 this year that hasn't
happened since the 50s in america and at
the same time you've got this whole
digitization occurring i call it the
great digitization 2.0 america 2.0
because everything's direct to consumer
including financial services and so
wonder if i is part of that trend you
talk about fiat currencies and we and
we're printing you know a trillion
dollars for infrastructure we're not
going to print that money in paper
that's going to be digital money and
every currency is eventually going to be
digital and so if you want to be part of
this transition you've got to place your
bets today in deals like wonderfi find
teams that are cutting edge we certainly
have that form partnerships with these
big players at the same time which i'm
doing and investing in them and you know
i have to tell you in the last 12 months
when i look at our deal flow more than
60 percent of my time today every day is
spent on defy looking at opportunities
investing in d5 managing our d5 accounts
consider that change in the last 18
months maybe it was three percent 18
months ago now it's 60. that's a huge
shift you know for those interested in
becoming part of wonderfuy's you know
eventual ecosystem do you have any
takeaways whether it's one two or three
that you would want consumers and even
some of your colleagues to walk away
with
you know i'm sort of an ambassador for
defy now and the reason i've done
wonderful is i want to be able to tell
people try it the whole idea is try it
put in a hundred dollars two hundred
dollars three hundred dollars start to
learn the mechanics of this incredible
market and this change in financial
servicing that that's occurring and the
role that ben and the team have to do is
they have to make it simple they have
got to make this really easy their
number one mandate is so that anybody
that's not familiar with defy can
download that app and use it and that's
the real opportunity that's at hand and
then once we've got that and we're
getting very very close to the team's
working 24 hours a day eight days a week
we're going to send that out to the
market and let everybody test it and
that's what josh and i have to do is
wave that flag and say we're here we
figured out a way to make this really
easy to use and now you can try it and
that's exactly what's going to happen
is there anything that scares you kevin
at all about the d5 space and this isn't
to
twist this into a negative context but
is there something that maybe
not really concerns you but still has
you a little bit hesitant that says look
we still got to pump the brakes a little
bit even though we're exploring this
we're excited about it but
you know is there anything that kind of
jumps out at you yes there is there
there is there is something that keeps
me up at night it's called compliance
the regulators and compliance i do not
ever given the size of my holdings and
all the financial services companies i'm
involved with as an investor ever to be
non-compliant i am not interested in
being a cowboy or being in the wild west
and there's a lot of people that think
that way about d5 but the point is this
is an institutional product emerging and
i come from that subset i have to be
compliant so i tell every one of my ceos
whatever you're doing i want it to be
compliant with the regulators i want to
know with certainty you've checked the
box there everything i do with every
company i invest in and when i deploy
capital into crypto i want to make sure
my own compliance team knows exactly
what's going on and that we're reporting
it correctly
you're absolutely right that is the area
of my uh my greatest concern because i
believe that the way we can make
cryptocurrency a standard globally is to
be compliant with it set the regs and
rules up so we can make it a standard
globally and i want to be part of that
as an investor but not on a
non-compliant basis
if you were able to provide some sort of
advice
consultation to some of these
traditional financial institutions
whether it's jp morgan chase capital one
about the future of d fire just the
future of banking in general
what would you tell them you know we've
seen chase as ceo kind of back and forth
over the years i mean what would you
want to tell them if you haven't already
well that's a that's an open dialogue
that happens every day in the markets as
people make decisions where they're
going to deploy capital you look at
what's going on right now in capital
generation look at the deals that have
been publicly announced circle 500
million in addition to another 400
million they just raised 900 millions
under their balance sheet their private
company the ftx 900 million all of these
these private companies in d5 are
raising capital in amounts that have
never been seen before in terms of the
size of this for private companies you
know at least these deals are huge and
that shows you where the deal flow is
going now
those investors could have invested in
money center banks but they chose not to
these were institutional clients that
said we don't want to be back there we
want to be where the puck is going and
so we're going to take these really big
bets and these are big bets when you
start talking about hundreds of millions
of dollars into private companies like
like circle and ftx you know something's
going on and so that is what's happening
capital is moving to where the puck is
going and that's defy that doesn't mean
the role of money center banks is going
to go away but certainly they have to
understand the competitive landscape for
money financial services is going
through a really rapid trans you know
transition and these ceos probably don't
have as much innovation in their
behemoth organizations as a young
entrepreneur sitting in the basement
typing out code and solving problems to
make d5 faster smarter you know and more
liquid and lower cost you talk about
some of these platforms that they charge
a fraction of what money center banks
charge so there's a lot of
democratization going on here and i
think what's going to happen and why i'm
an investor in all these private
companies is that i think these things
are going to get acquired by the money
center banks after they prove their
business models because these minor
center banks that are behemoths need
these services inside of what they do
so i think we're going to see a lot of
change a lot of disruption a lot of
turmoil and a lot of incredible
investment opportunities into d5 in the
next two years
what what can our millennial what can my
millennial generation and the gen z's do
better to to contribute to be of value
in this fintech space in this defy space
what what would you like to see from us
i've told my son the same thing he
called me up and said hey what's this
wonderful thing about you know and and i
said look this is an opportunity to
democratize investing make it less
expensive make it totally transparent
make it so that people can use crypto
and get interest off their holdings and
get income all of these things are
happening and so i tell everybody try it
just get yourself exposed to it try it
you don't have to go all in just educate
yourself which you can do online the
barrier to entry is very very low you
download wonderfuy as an app and you try
it and you learn from it that's the
whole idea this is a massive educational
process we're going to go through here
and people are going to realize wow i
can actually use this to have an
investment strategy where i can make
some income which is really well all i
wanted in the first place when i started
investigating this two and three years
ago it was look i've got a lot of cash
on the sidelines i sold some real estate
and i need to invest it and make two or
three or four percent interest and where
did that lead me
wonderful
that's where it led me and that's where
i am today
with shark tank you know i've grown up
watching you uh for for years and all i
have to say is is just thank you um for
doing what you do it you know it's taken
somebody like myself who
you know we've gone through college and
never really appreciated the financial
responsibility but having individuals
like yourself kevin where
yes it's tv but there's something to
learn from how you talk
the what what you teach um how does
defy and this world of digital money if
at all change the future in your opinion
of shark tank and maybe some
some different ventures that you
consider on set while you're filming
does does that come into play at all or
do you anticipate that coming into play
that's a great question and you're dead
right on this shark tank is actually a
snapshot of what america looks like is
going to look like in two years we are
so far ahead of the market now because
we have a hundred million eyeballs to
see the show each year in syndication
everybody knows that every entrepreneur
with a new and exciting disruptive idea
wants to come on shark tank now they
know that what they're doing is going to
be very important in 24 months so i like
to look at shark tank and we're in the
middle of shooting it right now season
13. every deal i'm seeing right now is
looking at the digital america 2.0
that's going to be here in 24 months
direct-to-consumer plays financial
services deals everything around
sustainability and ethically sourced
products all of this happening now on
shark tank it is a forecast of where
america is going to be in two years and
i'm loving it and you're dead right
there's all kinds of digital deals this
year that you could have never thought
of you know they step out on that carpet
and i say to myself why didn't i think
of that how is it i didn't do that
that's what i love about shark tank if
you like that video wait did you see my
next one don't forget to click right
over here and subscribe